Oh,
well,
good morning.
We'll uh,
we'll get started.
And as you know,
this isn't,
there isn't going to be a lecture this morning at all.
We're going instead to have a review session in which I'll be very much
dependent on your having questions and are having a joint discussion.
So what I'm expecting to be able to do is to,
when you have questions or want to contribute to,
I've got some questions as well.
Um,
we can put our heads together and there'll be a microphone.
I hope that we can pass around and there everyone will be audible.
So the first thing I should say is just to talk just for a minute about the exam
itself because I've now written it so at least we can say on that much,
I'm the world's authority.
So the exam will look like this.
There will be two parts.
The first part will be the ID section and that will have,
uh,
let's see,
you've got the list of identifications and I've literally just chosen 10 of
them.
And that will constitute two points each or a total of 20 points for the ID
section.
And so you can work out how to budget your time and not regard clearly.
You're not meant to write an essay,
just even bullet points or short paragraph is all that it's expected.
With regard to the identifications.
The second part of the exam consists of three essays and I'm at that is three on
the list of three and I'll ask you to write on two of them and each of the
essays.
Therefore we'll count 40 points.
So section part two of the exam,
we'll count 80 points altogether.
So that tells you how you should budget your time.
The essay questions are much more important than the identifications.
Um,
so that's really the structure of the exam.
I can't think really of anything else that I can say about that.
Uh,
but let me see if anyone before we turn to substantive issues.
Does anyone have any questions about the format of the exam or what's likely to
be on it?
I can repeat what I've said before.
The exam period itself is notionally three hours though.
You also get an additional half hour as a grace period.
Dot.
I understand is the elk system.
And Will um,
uh,
adhere to that.
The exam will also,
I wanted to stress this.
It will cover the whole of the course from the beginning and it won't simply be
on the last part of the course since the mid,
the mid term.
It will cover everything that we've dealt with since January down to g today.
So are there any questions before we turn to the substance about the format of
the exam or what you could expect or not expect or anything of that nature?
Yeah.
Do we need to bring in any of their meetings on the [inaudible] section?
The question was do you need to bring in readings on the ID section?
The uh,
I think that depends entirely on which id you deal with.
Some of the ideas are directly based on the reading that you've done.
You've done.
So for example,
if I asked,
um,
Daniel Defoe to identify,
it would be really odd if you didn't bring in the Journal of the play gears and
why it was important.
Um,
okay.
But if I asked you about,
say the Paris School of medicine that you didn't actually have readings on,
then it wouldn't be necessary.
So it really depends on the nature of the particular id in question.
Okay.
Um,
anything else about the exam?
Okay,
thanks.
Then let's move on to the substantive part of the review and,
uh,
the issues that we've been dealing with in the course.
And I thought one way we might start would be for me to ask you a question,
which is,
uh,
what do you think I should as sensibly ask you about on the final,
what would make good final exam questions for you based on the material that
you've covered.
Okay.
And then we could put our heads together a little bit to think about what might
be some elements are the answers that you provide in them.
Does anyone have a question that I want to ask you?
It's never too late.
I could change the questions I,
I wrote yesterday.
Okay.
You think I should ask you nothing.
It's always a possibility too.
Um,
okay.
Well,
I've got some thoughts,
um,
if you like,
uh,
for things that we might want to deal with.
Uh,
one was,
uh,
this,
and I'm going to ask and see if any of you would like to help me think through
this particular issue.
If we're dealing with,
uh,
the impact of a major epidemic diseases on society,
what would be,
is it true to think that it's really the overall mortality that provides the
major way in which we can assess whether this was an important event or it
wasn't?
It's not how we judge the significance of the passage of an epidemic disease
through society.
Do we,
uh,
is the body count,
in other words,
the most important factor,
or is it something else?
How do we,
what factors determine whether an epidemic disease really is a significant
historical event or it isn't?
Oh,
do you have any thoughts on that particular,
yeah.
Issue.
That's why.
Yes,
please.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thanks very much.
Did everyone get,
could you everyone here?
Uh,
the,
the counter that through an answer would be that it's not just the mortality,
but we need to look at the morbidity.
And even more than that,
we need to look at the class or the profile of the victims of the epidemic and
then it makes a big difference whether the victims of the disease are the
elderly and perhaps infants.
In other words,
whether it seems like a normal event in the life of that society or whether it
targets instead a different patient population.
If it targets people in the prime of life,
it's experienced in a very different way.
So clearly the class profile is important and not just the,
um,
the mortality or even the morbidity.
Are there other factors?
Yeah.
Mortality mattering.
Is that like you didn't really have much of an impact on assigning anything?
We'd ask him why?
Because people are stupid.
They didn't have like a really big morbidity,
small mortality answer that like,
okay.
Oh,
that's great.
Let me just see in fun.
I'm wondering if you could help me out
then people will be,
everyone will be able to hear.
Okay.
Um,
see it works.
We're in luck.
Maybe you could start again.
I don't think everyone can hear you.
Your question.
Yeah.
Um,
Oh God,
that's weird.
Um,
one argument in favor of mortality mattering is that at flu,
which didn't really have that much,
if the lasting impact on society had a really,
um,
high morbidity but a really small mortality and everyone knew that and so they
want like panicked when it
came.
Okay.
So there's the idea then that we shouldn't retreat too much for mortality,
that it really does matter and I'm really happy that you did something very
important,
which was not just to leave this matter hanging in the abstract but to talk it
to a particular example.
And so it's really important that you bring in particular diseases to clinch
your argument.
So talking about influences exactly the way that the argument ought to go on
weighing that versus other diseases that were different.
So,
so that's good.
Thank you.
Um,
right.
Someone else?
Oh,
there we go.
Um,
at the same time,
I think that at the same time,
I think that what that really speaks to is more the reaction of society to
something so that it's important to say that it's not just a number that
matters,
that mortality rate isn't so much the important part as much as how people were
able to kind of incorporate that into their lives.
Because as we were saying,
blue wasn't necessarily the most striking example to people.
However,
I think that certain,
even even times like tuberculosis where you have people who are dying but in
very much longer periods so you have more time for reactions and literature and
art.
Um,
and those have just as much of an impact and in fact it really lasting impact
because we still have those pieces of epidemic art and literature to look back
on to see how they had impact on society.
Okay.
Thanks very much.
So you want to complicate the matter even more.
It really depends on how it's perceived,
uh,
perceptions and also that's reflected in the arts and in literature.
And you're giving the example of tuberculosis and the time period.
And how are lasting the impact is so that tuberculosis has an,
a one of its reasons for having such an impact was that it was such a slow event
and was with society for so long and people reflected on that and it impacted
the arts and culture.
Um,
absolutely.
I think that would be,
so we've gotten now in order to deal with this,
we've dealt with influenza and tuberculosis as contrasting,
uh,
factors,
contract to diseases in very different ways.
And it's certainly true that also on the exam we will be dealing,
uh,
ask,
I'll be asking you to be comparative in your discussion of diseases and to bring
in more than one disease in order to,
uh,
deal with major questions that cut across the whole of our,
okay.
Thanks.
Any,
anything else we want to put into our answer to this question?
Uh,
would it be good to deal with just to,
uh,
diseases and dealing with that,
with this be a,
would you get an a plus for bringing in influenza and tuberculosis?
Uh,
what other diseases might be important in considering this question?
Yes,
thanks.
Mike is arriving
this one.
There we go.
We're sorting it out.
Okay.
Um,
you might consider cholera because,
um,
it was sort of the,
the opposite of tuberculosis and that it,
it had a very rapid onset.
And so the specific surrounding,
uh,
the disease itself had an effect on how it was perceived as something
frightening,
um,
and,
and something rose.
Okay.
Um,
so you would throw cholera into the mix.
And I think the reason you're say five understood.
You,
you're saying that this should take us into another whole realm,
which is to deal with the symptoms because there was something particularly
frightening and disgusting about Asiatic Cholera and not condition.
It's impact.
People were really terrified by its arrival because of the nature of its
symptomatology.
So that's another dimension that we ought to consider.
It's not just morbidity,
not just mortality,
not just the profile of the victims,
but the kind of suffering that the disease imposes on its victims.
So the symptomatology is tremendously important.
Okay.
Anything else on that question?
Where are our grade is going up all the time?
Uh,
you know,
several examples,
specific cases.
Um,
that's comparison.
That's all,
uh,
extremely important.
Uh,
anything else anyone wants to throw in on this question?
so collectively we've got an a plus on,
on this.
Uh,
okay.
Well,
pat ourselves on the back and let's,
uh,
let's move on and see if there are other issues we might like to discuss.
Um,
what is it?
I'll,
let me see.
I'm wondering,
I mentioned,
uh,
something in passing and throughout a phrase,
which was that we might want to consider some diseases in our course.
Uh,
diseases of modernity.
A,
I'm wondering if that's actually a useful concept.
It may be that I misspoke or,
uh,
is modernity in some senses of factor that promotes our vulnerability to high
impact epidemic diseases or at least certain ones among them?
Is that true or is that,
um,
you know,
is that wrong?
Great.
You really do.
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
I can hear you now.
All right.
I might put a finer edge on up for the class by asking them if any real progress
in social or medical response to epidemic disease as occurred over the time span
of the course.
Okay.
Um,
how were we?
In other words,
are we more vulnerable now?
We're much less vulnerable as a result of public health policies and
understanding of infectious diseases since,
uh,
let's see,
poor Daniel Defoe,
uh,
lived through the bubonic plague.
That's sort of your question,
right?
Precisely.
It struck me that you're interrupting for say it struck me that your definition
of a disease of maturity refers to structural factors,
right?
So for instance,
the role of like mass transit technologies,
perhaps like urbanization in the betting,
the spread of disease.
Isn't that the sense of disease of modernity or,
um,
I think you're right.
I'm a who knows what I meant when I said that,
but it would seem to me if we were retrospectively to try to make sense of a
phrase like that.
We,
and this is important in all,
here's the general point.
For any answers that you give in an exam,
you would have to provide a definition of what it actually means.
A modern deeds,
a lovely phrase,
but it doesn't really,
it's meaning is not self evident and it was only your grade would rise very
significantly if you weren't just to talk about Moderna.
But you were actually to do what you just did,
but to say,
what does that mean?
And point to factors such as urbanization,
mass transit,
population growth,
um,
things like that that give it a meaning.
Um,
and possibly also the development of an understanding scientifically of the
biology and the medicine of the diseases and therefore public health policies
and practices.
So that I think would be a much better way to approach this idea of whether it's
a disease of modernity or not.
And I'm just wondering,
what would you say,
are we less vulnerable now then?
Um,
London was at the time of defoe or,
um,
is it still the same or are we vulnerable but vulnerable to different kinds of
diseases are at least here in the,
in the West.
Okay,
great.
The microphones,
I'm arriving quick.
Ah,
okay.
We'll come to you immediately after.
Um,
I would say that we're more vulnerable to the spread of disease and two
diseases,
uh,
that are a result of over sanitation,
but there were also more capable of dealing with them scientifically and
technologically.
Okay.
So it's um,
neither at you're rejecting that opposition of being more or less vulnerable
were more vulnerable in certain ways and less vulnerable and others.
So perhaps we're not as susceptible to certain diseases in the same way,
but we're susceptible to other diseases in different ways.
Maybe the mode of transmission is an important factor,
but you want it to say something too.
So let's come to you.
MMM.
Is this working?
Yeah,
it's working.
Okay.
Um,
I also think that in a way though,
we're sort of like shifting from one vaguely misconception of disease cause I
would hate to another because like in the earliest modes of disease prevention
where you know,
quarantine and I'm just like whatever they could kind of like sanitation like
with Chadwick.
But then we moved to this like magic bullet thing once we figured out that it
was the germ theory and like for a really long time and I think like it's still
sort of process is this idea that we can hear something just by finding like a
magic drug and that isn't really how it works.
And there are a lot of other factors.
And even though like we sort of acknowledge that sometimes I don't think that
it's necessarily permeated our efforts to like to,
to cure a lot of different diseases.
Like with AIDS,
you can kind of see that there's like efforts at education and things like that,
but as long as there's poverty,
there's going to be diseases that disproportionately affect the poor.
And I don't think that we're anywhere near solving that problem.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I saw,
I understand that you're saying that,
uh,
we have made advances and understanding and there are diseases for which there
are public health measures that are effective and there are some times magic
bullets,
but we have become rather over,
we overemphasize the importance of treatments and we underestimate the social
economic determinants of disease.
And so,
uh,
diseases thrive on certain social and economic conditions.
And you mentioned poverty for example.
And so until those underlying,
uh,
substrates of epidemic diseases are dealt with will always remain vulnerable.
Um,
so that would suggest maybe we should take that on for a second and is not a
valid conclusion from the course,
from your readings and all the rest that diseases,
all diseases are diseases of poverty,
which seem to be something you were maybe suggesting or even if you weren't,
I'm suggesting it on your behalf,
uh,
is not,
a valid conclusion to draw that really the essential driver of epidemic
disasters is poverty.
Okay.
All diseases are diseases of poverty.
Is that,
is that right?
Yeah.
Right.
Great.
Thanks.
Okay.
Um,
I,
I would disagree with that statement because,
okay.
Although I would too,
we see that in some cases notably cholera,
it did only strike the poor and the rich were pretty much unaffected by the
disease.
In terms of uh,
health health wise,
um,
there has been plenty of other diseases that really haven't shown any liking to
any specific socioeconomic class.
Like the flu just came in and since it was so easily spread from person to
person,
um,
even if,
you know,
if you've,
you've,
you are walking into a store,
um,
run by someone of a lower class,
you could easily get that from them.
So I think most diseases,
even though some did strike the poor to a greater extent,
you can't pacify them solely as being diseases of poverty where poverty might
have,
um,
uh,
not embellished.
But poverty might have,
uh,
yeah,
the,
um,
it might've made it worse.
So,
uh,
someone in poverty would probably be worse off,
do the influencer then Richard Person.
But I don't think it caused most of the diseases we've talked about.
Okay.
So,
uh,
you,
there is the theory then that it really depends on which disease and that it's a
gross over simplification to say that poverty is the cause of epidemic disease.
It exacerbates the situation probably for all.
But there are clearly certain diseases that are driven by other factors.
And influenza was a case in point.
There are certain diseases that really do seem to be a equal opportunity
afflictions in that they,
uh,
seem to strike all wrong stuff.
Society rather than just certain economic and social classes and influencer was
a good respiratory diseases perhaps,
ah,
veer towards that pole.
But then I think you're saying that in any,
it's probably not fair also completely to eliminate poverty,
that that's a sort of spectrum and some diseases are more responsive to poverty
and others less,
but that even influenza,
perhaps if you're poor,
you don't have access to medical care,
to nursing,
to rev rec,
uh,
and to,
medications and so on.
And so it's more of a problem,
but it's a universal problem nonetheless,
if I understood you right correctly.
Okay,
good.
Thank you.
Okay.
Um,
I think you'd be right.
and I think it would be good if the end,
the answer are,
uh,
let's say we give them more coherent answer if we gave a range of diseases and
dealing with the answer.
So I'm at one end of the spectrum and others at the other,
right.
So influenza would be great,
but it would be a mistake just to put influence into the answer.
We'd want to give contrasting examples.
So the answer then as many historical answers is,
has to be qualified in nuanced and just a sec,
all diseases are diseases of poverty is probably quite wrong.
Okay.
There was a nother you were going to,
oh,
okay.
Okay.
Well,
why don't I be a really,
really nasty person and ask if you could help me out.
Um,
how would you rank them?
I enter
you've got lots of people to help you out.
You're not on your own.
Okay.
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
So a one end of the spectrum,
we put influenza and that would clearly be the least responsive to poverty as a
driver.
The other end of the spectrum,
you'd put Asiatic Cholera,
which is clearly very,
uh,
sensitive to social and economic factors to living conditions,
to Dirk and filth,
to lack of light to overcrowding.
I hope you would then you see in your essay,
uh,
poverty to a needs is not self evident.
What it means.
Why is poverty of factor,
and I hope you would talk about,
um,
you know,
filth,
uh,
access to medical care,
education,
overcrowding,
bad housing,
um,
sewage.
Um,
those are the things that the cholera thrives in on.
so you would be right that way,
putting influenza and cholera at opposite poles of the spectrum.
But once again,
we have to remember that this is not absolute because wealthy people also
succumbed to Asiatic cholera,
just in much smaller numbers.
Um,
okay.
Right.
Thanks.
Um,
I think I would put,
uh,
malaria and to a lesser extent the plague on the collar side of things in
malaria because,
um,
they,
it was a big working condition disease and a lot of people who were in the lower
classes worked in the rice fields were and worked in,
in,
uh,
in lived in areas that they couldn't have the simple protection against
mosquitoes.
And I said plug to a lesser extent on the,
on the Colorado side,
because as we saw in journal,
oh,
play gear,
a lot of the richer people were able to leave London and a use financial means
to get away from the disease.
And even though it spread,
um,
the poor people couldn't do that and they had to stay.
Okay.
So we have,
um,
a couple of other examples of diseases that might be a along the level of
poverty being driven by poverty and malaria was an example because of the
particularly labanear laboring and living conditions.
It's partly an occupational disease and so it strikes a peasants and people who
work in conditions that make them vulnerable and it's a house disease that
depends on overcrowding and living in housing.
That's a porous to flying insects.
Uh,
so poverty clearly is important to the spread of malaria.
We've seen,
uh,
to some extent that plague has some,
it could be argued either way,
but you're absolutely right to introduce plague as something,
a case to be argued as to whether it is or isn't.
A,
I'm wondering what about,
uh,
some other diseases transmitted differently?
You,
one factor might be then you might say it might depend partly on means of
transmission of the disease,
perhaps airborne diseases less driven by poverty ones.
Dot.
That travel by the oral fecal route or by vectors might be important.
What about sexually transmitted diseases and it's syphilis,
a disease of poverty.
Um,
you wanted to,
uh,
I would put aids and syphilis towards the flu end of things.
Okay.
Although
by modern maps of where these diseases are highly
prevalent,
it would seem otherwise,
but I think that there is actually,
you know,
a sort of
not poverty based for that.
So,
okay.
uh,
we have a candidate then for,
two other candidates to go at the influenza end of the spectrum,
syphilis and aids.
Um,
I'm wondering if everyone would agree with that.
Yeah,
please.
Oh,
sorry.
You go ahead first.
Yeah.
I would put aids more towards the middle of this spectrum because aids did have
a predilection for marginalized groups,
but at the same time it could affect anyone,
including,
you know,
a,
a heterosexual man from a wealthy family.
Um,
so,
so I think it sort of goes in the middle.
If I could add one to the list,
maybe I would put SARS as closer to the flu end of the spectrum.
Because it,
it did seem to,
and this adds to the idea that airborne diseases are less driven by poverty
because,
um,
it did seem to affect everyone but at the same time did hit areas that had
strong health infrastructure and that helped to quell the disease.
Someone.
Okay.
I'm wondering,
I like your answer and I'm just wondering if with HIV AIDS you,
we would want even to make distinctions in that HIV age seems to have different
phases and different epidemiologists according to different circumstances and
not in the industrial west.
It seems to be a disease,
more marginal groups at least at the moment at use not to be.
When it was first introduced into the United States for example,
it wasn't example of a socioeconomic marginality but rather people who because
of sexual orientation or uh,
their,
uh,
through blood supplies and so forth.
But it would seem that if you were dealing at a global level now with AIDS in
Africa for example,
poverty does seem to be a very important factor in,
in the disease.
Would you not agree with that
or,
yeah,
definitely.
I think,
um,
in,
in countries where there is more,
well that's,
it's seen more as a chronic disease.
So definitely.
Great.
Well thank you.
So,
um,
we could even talk at devops,
break some of the diseases down into different periods in their,
uh,
their transmission and you wanted to add something.
Oh,
that was that what you wanted to add?
Okay,
cool.
There's another,
oh,
thank you.
Um,
I was just going to say that tuberculosis should be added to the list probably
more on the end of,
um,
influenza simply because they kind of regarded it as a disease of the rich for
some time.
And the disease of genius,
I think it was because of the people that it affected.
And um,
okay.
Uh,
so there's,
uh,
the thought that may be tuberculosis ought to be added to the influence and of
the spectrum in that it seemed to be looking back on the 19th century experience
of the disease,
it was even described as a disease of beauty of genius.
And it clearly we can make a long list of high society people,
celebrities,
artists are kings and Queens who were afflicted by tuberculosis.
And I think that if you are dealing with the 19th century,
that would be a splendid argument to make.
And I agree with you entirely.
I'm just wondering though,
if we come forward fast forward in time to today,
then I think we have to say that the epidemiology of tuberculosis today is
different and that it thrives on pre existing conditions on overcrowding.
Um,
aunt.
So I think the,
the time period can also be important.
Tuberculosis has retreated to areas of poverty,
I would argue are now,
would you agree with that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I was going to say that.
Um,
what do you were just talking about how like different time era is actually can
delineate whether or not it is a disease of poverty here,
not just by the people that it affects the effect it has on the society at the
present moment.
Okay.
Thanks very much.
Yes.
So I think we're seeing that I'm describing a d I diseases as diseases of
poverty is really a complex,
uh,
and also,
um,
debatable position.
And it depends on what diseases,
where,
when,
and so forth.
So it's actually one needs to break down.
What poverty is and one needs to have a spectrum of diseases.
Uh,
but I think we're dealing with it much more effectively.
And I think one of the things we see is it,
the more complexity,
the more nuance,
uh,
the better our answer is becoming.
Also,
the more interesting,
uh,
I think it's rather a blend and not very convincing answer to say simply all
diseases are diseases of poverty.
And I think we now see that actually the situation is much more complex than not
that poverty is an important factor,
but it doesn't simply,
we can't reduce our course to that one variable.
Okay.
Um,
in the meanwhile,
have you thought of other questions that,
uh,
that we ought to be dealing with in our course?
Or should I put it another way?
Are there major themes in our course?
What could we make maybe a short list of themes that you should be thinking
about as you do your revision?
What are the major themes that we've been dealing with this semester?
Uh,
disease and poverty as an example.
Um,
are there other themes
go for it?
Um,
I guess another theme has been the magic bullet theory of combating disease in
the idea that any disease can be solved basically by,
I'm coming sort of coming up with some sort of scientific cure that uh,
such as,
uh,
I guess the Queen in the case of malaria.
Um,
I guess in the case of right Queenie and then DDT in the case of malaria.
And I guess that theme has been one that has sort of been one underlying,
um,
what has been sort of this tram for age of American medicine and one that I
think,
uh,
at least in emerging and reemerging disease,
is it something that we're increasingly viewing as not exactly the most
effective way of dealing with it,
but that one disease.
Okay.
Thanks very much.
Yes.
One of the,
another theme of our course has been the tendency to think of finding a magic
bullet to each infectious disease.
And you were just starting to do what I think would then be really important if
that were a question on the final,
which is to look at what is the history of magic bullets and have they actually
delivered on the promise associated with them and examples that you gave.
Um,
let's see.
Quinine with regard to malaria,
um,
or later on Ddt with regard to malaria.
And how's that,
would that be with malaria be a good example of a disease that's been highly
responsive to magic bullets?
Huh?
And you were shaking your head,
ah,
do you want to add to your head shake,
um,
mass treatment?
And it was all sort of,
um,
to malaria.
And there were other social factors that weren't considered.
Um,
and people were thinking at the time that if we applied a DVD for a certain
amount of time,
the malaria eradicated forever,
but that certainly wasn't the case.
And conditions could change in the disease.
I think it was the case,
um,
in near,
near Italy where they built the dam and then during the war the dam was broken
and then later the disease came back during the war.
So these measures aren't permit as they thought they were.
They initially were.
So in that sense,
this magic bullet,
um,
can't be the permanent,
I don't answer.
Okay.
So we have,
um,
a problem with malaria.
There was this great euphoria of thinking that a magic bullet could be found and
quinine and Dee Dee tee,
we're examples.
Um,
but they ended up not actually delivering on the promise.
Chloroquine would be yet another example,
uh,
of a magic bullet for dealing with malaria.
So I would agree entirely.
Malaria would be a wonderful example of enormous expectations of a magic bullet
as a solution.
And yet we see that in fact,
uh,
the biology of the disease is much more complicated than being dealt with and
not way.
And we've seen resistance being developed by mosquitoes and by plasmodium.
And so the promise of the magic bullets with malaria turned out to be a tool and
they're useful,
but they haven't rid the world at all of the disease.
And there was,
you wanted also to say something.
Yeah.
And I think to go along with that,
um,
there's another reason why magic boats can't entirely work in,
that's another theme of the class,
which is the idea of disease as a social construction.
And the fact is that even if a magic bullet can,
um,
have a great effect on the biology or the symptomatology of a disease,
I think Barnes is the author who really went into the idea that in order to
really attack a disease,
it,
it goes into the substratum of society,
into our ideas about disease and what we placed,
the stigma that we place on.
Okay.
Um,
so,
uh,
we can't just think in terms of magic bullets,
we also have to think about the ideas in people's heads.
How do they understand the disease?
What's the social construction?
And you gave the example of tuberculosis,
um,
as,
as a good example.
Okay.
I would entirely agree with that too.
Um,
I'm wondering if there are other examples of magic bullets that have either
delivered on the promise or have failed to deliver on the promise.
What we've talked about,
malaria,
quinine,
DDT,
chloroquine.
Um,
what about other,
I have magic bullets played a role in our course with other diseases.
Yeah,
go for it.
The original magic bullet was this with syphilis though,
right?
Penicillin.
Um,
and I think that was a pretty good example.
I mean,
brands point in a magic bullet is the,
it didn't really,
I mean it helped but it didn't really slow the incidents.
Like it would sort of go Creston waves where there were,
you know,
people who were soldiers in the army and they would get prostitutes and then it
kind of didn't really matter whether there was a cure for syphilis or not
because like they just wouldn't have access to it.
Like even if they,
even if they can track to the disease.
So,
um,
education and other programs like that are just as important as,
drugs when it comes to preventing something like an STD.
Okay.
So the history of syphilis would be another good study for whether magic bullets
are the way to eradicate or control a major diseases.
And you,
you use the example of penicillin,
which is a good one,
but I think we've had with syphilis even further back,
other things that at the time were thought of as magic bullets,
uh,
mercury before that.
And salverson would be other earlier,
uh,
ideas of,
considered magic bullets that also didn't eliminate the disease.
The diseases tend to be much more complicated than to be simply amenable to a
magic bullet solution.
So syphilis is another example along with malaria,
right?
Uh,
are there other examples?
Yeah.
One instance where this magic bullet idea did it seem to work was in the case of
smallpox where,
um,
a vaccine was developed and given to all the population such that the disease no
longer had a host of humans or reserve pool of posts in effect,
and the disease eventually was radicating.
Um,
and I think that's one example where this magic bullet was,
um,
was effective,
but it was a very special case,
um,
in the,
in,
in the case of smallpox because this cow pox vaccine was very effective.
And I think we talked about how,
um,
it's very much disease specific and smallpox seem to themes to be an exception
rather than the rule in terms of how magical it can work.
Okay,
thanks.
Um,
so we need to be careful or even in our CEP skepticism about magic bullets that
there may be cases when they can actually work.
And a good example being smallpox in which the vaccine how's actually eradicate,
it's naturally occurring smallpox from the world.
So there are examples,
but then one ha,
you were also saying what lesson should be drawn from smallpox?
And you were saying perhaps one of the lessons though is it smallpox is
atypical.
It had certain specific features about it that made it particularly vulnerable
to attack by vaccination,
but,
uh,
we can't throw out then the hope for finding tools that will actually eradicate
diseases.
And smallpox is an example of something that really did work.
Yeah.
Okay.
Any other examples?
It ought to be thrown into our mix.
MMM.
How about TB?
And streptomycin would be,
uh,
another example I would think of,
um,
uh,
something that seemed after World War Two that it would be possible to close all
of the sanitary IA and that was largely happen.
And the,
uh,
outlook seem to be that TB would be eliminated by this magic bullet.
But we see again,
the problem of drug resistance and we're living now in a world in which there's
multiple drug resistant tuberculosis.
And so once again,
the,
we have an example of a disease that's been much more recalcitrant because we
see the,
I guess,
um,
that Darwin was right,
the influence of evolution and its impact on,
uh,
the microbes surrounding us.
Um,
okay.
Is there another major theme of our course?
We've seen magic bullets.
We've seen,
uh,
poverty.
Uh,
we've seen modes of transmission as major impacts on disease.
we've talked about mortality,
morbidity,
and whether how you,
what are the contributes symptomatology,
what are the factors that contribute to the impact of a disease on society?
We have just a few more minutes.
So I'm wondering if we have,
uh,
at least one more candidate for a major theme of our course.
Yeah,
the evolution of public health strategies in response to the epidemic disease.
Okay.
Uh,
that's not fair.
You read my mind.
I was thinking of exactly that and I did want to say that it would be
unfortunate if you went to the final examine our course without also thinking
about public health as a major theme that we've covered in our course.
And let me just,
shall I,
could we make lists now?
We don't have time for a discussion,
but what are some of the major forms of public health strategy that we have
talked about?
Okay.
Quarantine and might be,
we might and large that by saying,
could we talk about plague strategies of defense against infectious disease,
meaning quarantines sanitary,
cordons,
possibly lots of the out toasts and pest houses.
Um,
all the rest that go with that.
Yes,
that's a recur and that's not only against plug,
but plug strategies were rolled out again and again and our course,
we've seen them applied not very helpfully against cholera.
We've seen them also a plagued strategies being applied against HIV AIDS in the
early days.
Um,
okay.
So that's one style of public health.
Um,
what other measures of public health have we seen?
Yeah.
Steelman educational campaign.
Okay.
You've got a list here that saw three more styles.
We've seen vaccination as,
uh,
you remember going back to Edward Jenner and that was a long time ago,
I admit,
but,
um,
that's important to remember.
Um,
there were,
we've also seen concealment and we saw concealment.
In the case of star SARS,
it came a occurred,
um,
in the case of cholera in our course.
Um,
we've talked about education as a impact on public health.
Are there other styles of public health that we've come across?
Yes.
Okay.
Uh,
we've seen public health based on my asthma twosome and,
uh,
with the fill theory of disease and uh,
therefore,
uh,
sanitation,
introducing,
uh,
urban cleanups,
sewer systems,
um,
even the rebuilding of cities.
Uh,
as we saw under oh,
small town in France and we saw that in the rebuilding of Naples also.
So those are additional styles of public health.
Um,
anything else anyone wants to throw in?
Huh?
Or is there a maybe another question,
a final sort of question or theme of the course?
We've just briefly suggested public health and a few dimensions.
Um,
there are others and I hope that you'll dig out,
dig them out.
Also,
are there any,
is there any final question that anyone wants to,
to bring up?
Yeah.
Okay.
We could discuss also the way in which,
uh,
the modern state has played a role in the control of disease and that we can see
that,
uh,
in tuberculosis through dispensary's Sanatoria we can see that also playing a
role through malaria.
And the same sort of idea of,
uh,
of dispensary's again.
And there are other diseases as well.
The state playing a role in education,
the state playing a role in the plague measures also.
So I think we can see the role of the state as a major player.
A central player in public health could indeed be an important theme of our
class.
Uh,
but having said that,
uh,
another theme is stomping,
when we've run out of time.
And so I'll do that and wish you good luck on the final and thank you this
morning for helping us put our heads together.
And I liked euro.
Your comments.
Thanks very much.